[Music]
is a concept about which we know
frighteningly little
your desecration of reality
it was the only way
but i never
meant for any of this
to happen
[Music]
later you'd show up
i made mistakes
and people were hurt i'm not here to
talk about westview
then what are you here for
i need your help
guess what
what do you know about the multiverse
[Music]
i'm sorry steven
i hope you understand
the greatest threat
to our universe
[Music]
is you
things just got out of hand
july 20th
1969
[Music]
in school you were taught that apollo 11
lost contact with the world for two
minutes
[Music]
not true
they found something on that day
that they kept him for 50 years
and now
it's too late to
in stop news the governor has just
ordered the mass evacuation of the
entire west coast
moving to higher ground it's the only
possible chance of surviving
stay away my brothers and sisters stay
awake
this planet
has suffered five extinctions
this
is going to be the sixth
oh he dead
you know we are just inside the moon
that might be the greatest sentence
anyone's ever said
[Music]
[Music]
who's swaying
sorry i wouldn't be bothering you here
but your people keep telling me you're
unavailable
you know you really could be doing more
for this
my city has a history of philanthropy
but as far as i can tell you're not
doing anything
the riddler
is asking for you the killer left this
for the batman why is he writing to you
are you okay
i've been trying to reach you
look there's latest it's all about the
wings
if we don't stand up no one will
you got a lot of cats i have a thing
about strength
the bat and the cat
it's got a nice ring new friend of yours
i'm not so sure
i'm just here to unmask the truth about
this cesspool we call a city
you're part of this too
how am i part of this
oh you're really not as smart as i
thought you were
bruce
wayne
we all have our scars bruce you're still
away
he's involved in this oh he's not
involved how do you know lenny
who are you under there
what are you hiding selena they'll throw
your life away
don't worry honey i got nine of them
it can be cruel poetic or blind
but when it's denied it's your violence
you may find
justice
the answer's justice
come on vengeance
let's get into some trouble
[Music]
quick stretch little snack and here we
go
sonic i love that you want to help make
a difference
if you're being reckless don't worry
nobody's gonna get hurt
pretending to be batman blue justice
trademark pending
you're still just a kid
trust me there will come a moment when
your powers will be needed
but you don't choose that moment that
moment chooses you i just got goosebumps
wait a second did you steal that from
oprah
papa's got a brand new stash
since i've been gone i've discovered the
source of ultimate power
that sounds big
it's been on my vision board for years
hope i'm not too late
i'm sorry who are you memes tales okay
this is what we're gonna do step one
light taunting step two i have no idea
[Music]
that wasn't too bad
today's forecast calls for a 100 chance
of adventure
[Music]
you're never going to get my power
do i look like i need your power
where
are my manners sonic meet knuckles
[Music]
flight recorders are on
t minus five
four
three
two
one
zero
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
to infinity
and
[Music]
mrs wang are you with us
i am paying attention
now you may only see a pile of receipts
but i see a story
i can see where this story is going
it does not look
good
what's happening
i'm not your husband i'm one of the
first uniforms from another universe i'm
here because we need your help
very busy today so time to help you
across the multiverse
i've seen thousands of evelyn's
you can access all the memories their
emotions
even their skills
there's a great evil spreading the many
verses
and you
may be your only chance of stopping it
don't make me find you i am really good
i don't believe you
he's waiting in the wings the universe
he speaks of senseless things is so much
bigger
than you realize
of all the places
there is no way i am the evelyn you are
looking for
every rejection
every disappointment
has led you here
to this
moment
don't let anything distract you from it
[Music]
[Music]
do you need a doctor
i am a doctor
i should have died years ago
people all over the world have my
disease i'm here
to find a cure
we have to push the boundaries take the
risks if you're gonna run
do it
dr now morbius you've been missing for
two months when you're a stranger then
you were found on a container ship that
washed up off a long island
when you're alone
what did you do to yourself doctor
i wish i knew
i went from dying to being more alive
than ever it worked
not exactly i have increased strength
and speed
and some form of bad radar
what else can i do
[Music]
there are limits there has to be there's
something inside of you he wants to hunt
and consume blood
can you control it
half the city wants to kill you
we haven't had anything this good since
that thing in san francisco
other half wants to control you hey uh
dr mike you and i should stay in touch
not doing anything to save a life
but i don't know what i'm capable of
you save lives you don't take them
are you here to heal the world
or to destroy it
who the hell are you mad i
am i know
i'm just kidding it's dr michael
morvious at your service
[Music]
she was
[Music]
you don't make it easy
you got a minute oh what
whoa
when how did she
how did you get
how have you been
it's a long story
is this the room you grew up in uh it is
but uh my my dorm room is very adult
right no of course
hey are these your drawings what no no
good
i missed you too
okay
so
what are you doing here
i mean i i thought i'd
never see you again
want to get out of here
[Music]
i'm grounded
bummer
is spider-man grounded
um
i mean i
[Music]
oh
so
[Music]
[Music]
she's down
[Applause]
so
[Music]
tell me something
[Music]
you can go
anywhere you want right
any timeline
and the universe
[Music]
why do you want to stay
and fight to save this one
you change the future
and you change the path
are you in
oh
[Music]
you